all right welcome back everybody two
years ago my next guest used Tik Tok to
land a book deal since then she released
light Lark which became a bestselling
and soon to be movie now she's back with
the sequel It's called night Bane and
it's one of the most anticipated young
adult novels of the year please welcome
back to the show Alex
[Applause]
Aster
I'm so good I love having you back this
is so exciting I'm so excited your life
just keeps getting better and better
it's changed since the last time I was
here honestly thanks to your show a lot
too so thank you for than to you girl
look at you're right I love this I have
to ask it's my favorite thing I learned
so you name your villains in your books
off of people you don't
like so I you should have been a
songwriter I'm just same so Kelly I
follow the Taylor Swift rule of writing
if you do not want a song or a book
written about you don't be mean don't be
mean to writers so yeah that's your
fault that's on you yeah yeah in in
reality I always need names like when
you're writing a book sometimes you use
a filler name and so I just kind of
thought one day hm I need a name for the
villain and I was like I don't really
like that person maybe they would be the
good person to like fit in there um they
don't usually end up in the final copy
one because I don't want to be sued and
you are smart as well and two because
their names are never that interesting
like I write fantasy so you can't have
like a Chad be the villain of like a
fantasy book Chad wears a puka shell
necklace yeah yeah it's not like
competing in a deadly game so yeah so I
usually do change it but it's a habit
that I've developed and I post a lot
about it and so the funny part is that
thousands of people will comment on my
post with name suggestions oh my God
like yes please like Julie or like
they'll just name so I have a a whole
list of names I don't even need to think
about my own anymore well catch us catch
us up on the series what's going on
right now so for anyone that isn't
familiar light Lark is about an island
that appears once every hundred years to
host a game where six rulers fight to
break their deadly curses so to break
them all one of the six rulers has to
die and one will win unmatched power so
there's Adventure romance big plot twist
you don't know who's lying until the
very last page and night Bane the next
book which is out now starts exactly
where light Lark ends so you can almost
read it like a giant book
yes and like the last time I was here I
said it's being made into a movie
franchise by Universal and the people
behind very big young adult series that
you might know that's amazing I'm so
excited for you yeah I'm so excited too
I I was here exactly a year ago and it
was just the beginning of lightl and now
night brain's coming out so it's really
God was what was your like favorite
genre like growing up what was your
favorite book genre my favorite book
genre growing up was the genre I'm
writing in now young adult fantasy so my
favorite book was Twilight growing up
it was the first book that I ever read
that I was like Wow reading can be
really fun and so I set out to write
books that could really be Escapist and
like get people out of their normal
world so that's what I write now get
people interested in Reading as well
exactly cuz a lot of people like the
young adult fantasy that kind of thing
yes adults read it too like most of the
the oh I read all that too yeah my
mother and I are big into that we always
I love a series I hate when it's one
book I'm like a now you can read both
books and like just combine them both I
love that love a Ser so I heard that you
also said um Jin jy's ears are like
different types of readers yes so do you
mean I think that people think that now
with social media people's attention
spans and like kids aren't reading but
now in the last few years it's honestly
the opposite and it's kind of funny
because social media is getting people
reading so my books were discovered on
social media and so many more millions
of books are being discovered and these
people now are becoming readers like you
said you just need one book to get you
into reading and then you're a lifelong
reader so people are discovering my
books on social media and they're
becoming readers so it's it's really
interesting how social media now is
making people read whereas I think the
public perception is that jenz isn't
reading but they're reading now more
than ever book sales are up so it's
great yeah it is interesting too for any
generation I just think it has to be um
something you're interested in right CU
my sister even we were talking about
thisday and um you know we're both over
40 and she she was like you know I never
really liked reading until you showed me
and I don't know if it was Jane Austin
or Jane or something that was um as an
author of the book but I I I don't know
which one it was but she was like really
got me in and then that thing opened up
now she reads more books than I will
ever read in my entire life that one
book like how do you have the time I'm
like yeah I know and and so I was
honestly writing the books that I wanted
to read and so that's the best thing to
do yeah yeah that's like how I want to
make shows they're like we should do a
show and I'm like but I want to make one
I want to watch yes I think that when it
starts from that place it can always be
good because there's people like you who
would want to read it or watch it AB
absolutely it's relatable so do your
fans come up with theories for your
books do you get like as well as names
do they often send you ideas yes and
actually only two people know like how
the series ends and I have to keep it a
secret because I'm just so afraid that
people will know like there's a love
triangle in the book and people are very
fiercely like team Oro or team grim and
so people want to know who she 's up
with so I really I have to keep it a
secret as much as I share on social
media I have to keep some stuff secret
about AB the plot my mother's the worst
my mother when you said the last page
you find out on the last page my mother
starts at the last page I'm not kidding
she is giant spoiler she's like oh I
just went to the end to see and I was
like we missed the whole ride like the
whole I was like it drives me nuts but
she does that so I'm going to tell her
not to start with the last page um do
you have any advice for like aspiring
writers because you came in the industry
in a very different way yes yeah I
always say never give up I started
writing books when I was 12 years old
this has been my dream since I was a
child and it just it didn't work I got
hundreds of rejections with every book
and this book light Lark was rejected by
16 Publishers almost every single
publisher rejected it and now it's been
in New York Times a seller for over a
straight year so like you just never
know got find some who and it's it's
because of the readers they did this so
as long as you put yourself out there
you don't need to wait for The
Gatekeepers to let you in you can truly
especially now with social media and
self-publishing you can create your own
destiny and so I I truly advise anyone
who's writing just put your work out
there you never know what's going to
happen absolutely and it's interesting
you mentioned Taylor earlier she um well
there's been a lot of tailor on the show
um but it's interesting because I
remember hearing in Nashville she got
turned down by so many people and then
finally got her opportunity and that's
biggest star on the planet you just need
one yes yeah you need one yes and you
need a team that believes in it yeah I
agree with that and I think it's a
really cool thing to tell people too
because people can give up or get
disheartened you know pretty easily
especially creative people yeah well all
right night Bane the sequel to the
bestselling book light Lark is available
now y'all got to go check it out get a
[Music]
copy
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home